there's a super interesting new piece in
the nation
written by sasha abramsky which says
that there are now
even some republicans worried that
indeed donald trump is trying to figure
out how to retain
control regardless of the outcome
of the november election which is now
under eight weeks away it's eight weeks
minus one day
and they're actually using the word
coup to describe the possibility
of what donald trump may do if indeed he
loses to joe biden
on november 3rd and this article by
sasha abramsky in the nation which we're
linking to and i encourage you to read
quotes charles freed charles fried is a
harvard law school professor still a
republican as far as far as i know right
now
and charles freed is increasingly
worried about donald trump's electoral
strategy
of seemingly encouraging chaos and
violence and is even
talking about how this strategy is ripe
for donald trump to actually send in
provocateurs
into largely left-leaning protests in
order to make them seem more violent
in order to try to justify his
re-election
or as a sort of double goal to
claim that things are so crazy we can't
really be sure the election was done
correctly
if he doesn't win and this is a classic
authoritarian provocateur
strategy we we've seen this the world
over we've seen it for decades and
decades
that's charles freed michael steele the
former chair
of the republican national committee
we've talked about him on the program
relatively
a well-known individual he is also
concerned
about the same possibility in november
and the the difference would be michael
steele
doesn't so much think that what's going
on is primarily
authoritarianism but michael steele
believes that it's really political
opportunism
and trump being uh determined
to retain control from a politically
uh uh advantageous perspective rather
than simply sheer authoritarianism but
the main takeaway
and the most important point here is
that both charles freed and michael
steele believe that donald trump is
willing to do whatever he needs to do to
remain in the white house
and trump has been signaling this by
attacking vote by mail
he's been saying he knows the election
will be rigged it'll be the worst the
most rigged most fraudulent election in
history he's said this probably dozens
if not hundreds of times at this point
and has been setting up a situation
where
he lays the groundwork not to accept the
the results of the election and then who
knows what happens
now what we're seeing is that there are
actually republicans
getting together with progressive
organizations
to develop a specific plan for
responding to trump rejecting the
results of the election
if he were to lose and they put together
a report
and unfortunately they are not confident
that our institutions will do their jobs
they are saying it could take
huge numbers of americans taking to the
streets
to make their will be reflected
in donald trump leaving if indeed donald
trump loses the election and claims that
it was
rigged and these groups which again they
now
include republicans these are not left
movements
uniquely republicans are also concerned
they're also worried that donald trump
will do something i've been predicting
for a long time which is that
if donald trump is ahead in certain
states
on election night this is the red mirage
scenario
trump will deploy lawyers to file
lawsuits
in various states to try to stop the
counting of absentee ballots which if
fully counted
could turn a small trump margin on
election night into a small biden margin
and hand a hand joe biden the presidency
the in the indivisibility project stand
up america are two of these groups
they're bringing together a whole bunch
of different organizations to try to
have a really specific plan
to prevent the electoral process from
being undermined and subverted
and disenfranchisement from running wild
now i still maintain
that donald trump will not succeed at
maintaining power if he loses
i believe that he he will go if he loses
but there is the very real possibility
that he will try
and that he could create absolute and
total chaos for some time including
possibly violence on the streets
ultimately the way that this becomes
dangerous in a physical violence sense
is if it's close and trump wins
on election night but starts to say
they're trying to take it from me i need
you out there
or loses by a small margin on election
night and says it was rigged
i think those two scenarios are the ones
that will most likely
weaponize and that's literally what it
would be his supporters with guns to go
out on the street now there's another
side to this
they are talking about the word coup as
if a coup would be necessary the
unfortunate reality
is that you don't need a coup to
undermine democracy and the will of the
people
because the electoral college has helped
republicans do that in multiple
elections over the last several decades
you can combine the disenfranchising
nature of the electoral college
with the suppression of the vote and
everything else that we're seeing where
you wouldn't even really need a coup in
other words trump may be able to pull
this off
simply with doing enough voter
suppression
enough voter purges etc that the
electoral college hands him a victory
even when he lost loses the popular vote
and really should have lost the
electoral vote as well
the point is we have to be ready for
this and it is not merely the stuff of
imagination
theory and fantasy at this point we've
seen the groundwork laid in real time
proclaiming that this election which
could remove donald trump
uh um will be
the most rigged and fraudulent one in
history and my biggest concern is what
is the joe biden campaign doing about it
to be ready
what are democrats doing about this to
be ready because if they aren't ready
that would be a disaster they need i was
going to say just as many lawyers
they probably need twice as many lawyers
as trump has ready
to try to stop counting absentee ballots
they need twice as many lawyers to
ensure that absentee ballots are counted
and it actually could come down to that
it could get very ugly very quickly
i'm not confident that the biden
campaign and the democratic party are
ready why
because they've been not ready so many
other times in history but
they absolutely need a plan they need
the lawyers ready to go
and we're going to be very closely
following whether they do have that
system in place
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn
from your checking account but your real
card number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number
in your web browser on the phone you can
create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman